- [Man on Right] Oh hello, Barbie.
- [Man on Left] Bro, you need
to just chill out for a sec.
All right, you're a little too excited.
- [Man on Right] I'm just
excited for your date tonight.
- Okay, you've been single for too long.
(dreamy pop music)
- Even though I didn't play with Barbie,
I always had a crush on her.
- Typically, it was just naked Barbie
being rescued by G.I. Joe.
- I was an awkward kid.
I couldn't even talk to girls
in school, let alone dolls.
- [Voiceover] We're gonna play dress up,
'cause you've got a date with Ken tonight.
- Have we met Ken before?
- Maybe just give him one shot.
- Okay.
- [Man on Right] We'll hang out
with him, and we'll see where it goes.
(record scratching)
(upbeat pop music)
- Barbie, put on your dress!
- [Man in Plaid] Oh God.
[Man on Right] He's gonna
be here in 10 minutes!
- [Man in Plaid] Okay.
- I'm a big fan of the classics.
We're gonna go with
the little black dress.
- This is harder than dressing
my four-year-old daughter.
- Do we only have one option on shoes?
These do not go.
- Accessorize, people.
Remember, accessories are important.
- Okay, just zip me up.
Don't get frisky.
- [Man on Right] Zip.
- [Man on Right] All right.
- [Man in Plaid] What are you do--
- I have never seen a
Barbie look that good.
- That's actually kind of
an A plus first date outfit.
- Barbie's going with a classic look.
- She wants to look
versatile, yet fashionable.
- [Both] Ohh!
(techno music)
- Ken, oh my God, Ken!
Ken, oh my God, Ken.
- [Man on Right] Thank you so
much for meeting me tonight.
- Am I supposed to be Ken?
- For right know, I'd just appreciate it
if you would be Ken for a little bit.
- [Man on Left] Maybe we
could talk about that more
over dinner.
- You know who's driving.
- [Man in Black] Hey, babe!
(loud smooch)
- I feel absolutely silly right now.
- Ready?
Pedal to the metal.
(car whirring)
(pop electro music)
- Woah!
- Oh my!
- Ken took Barbie on a date to her house?
That's a power move.
He got her in the car and was like,
"Barbie, we're going out
"to your house."
- [Man on Right] You're gonna
notice the Italian marble.
- [Man on Left] Very nice.
- That didn't come cheap, but then again,
I'm not a cheap girl.
(toilet flushing)
- Barbie, what are you doing in there?
- Not pooping!
- Wee.
- That is the coolest thing
I've ever done with a toy.
- [Main in Black] Oh wait,
you know what's dope?
- Oh, second floor
- [Man in Black] Second story
- [Both] Jacuzzi!
- [Man in Black] Ahh!
(romantic acoustic music)
- [Man on Right] Ken, we're
here in my bedroom right now.
- [Man on Left] Yes.
- Okay, but guess what?
Before anything would
happen here in this bedroom,
I need to know that you're
thinking about marriage.
(man on left laughing)
- [Voiceover] I had fun
exploring this dream house.
There's a lot to find.
- When my sister had her Barbies,
I wouldn't play with them,
but now I kinda brought
them into my world.
- I do kind of wish I
did play with Barbies.
- You see Barbie and you
expect her to be one way,
but when you get the toys and
you actually play with them
it's whatever you want it to be.
- [Man on Right] Oh my gosh, Ken.
- [Man on Left] I dance
better than Drake though
in that Hotline Bling song, don't I?
- Right now, I think I'm more concerned
with a song called Hotline Ken.